- Just takin' a little selfie.
(laughs)
(funky horn music)
- I am recreating Michael
Jackson's Thriller.
- I will be recreating Missy
Elliott's Under Construction.
- The Score by the Fugees.
- Diana Ross's debut solo album.
- Dirty Mind by Prince.
- The album cover I'm recreating
is the Janet Jackson self entitled album.
- Solange Knowles, A Seat at the Table.
- We got Outkast, the album is Stankonia.
- Mike is going to be Big Boi.
- Yep.
And Richard's gonna be Andre 3000.
- My hair's a little short right now,
so am I gonna get to wear a wig?
Alright.
(rhythm and blues)
- On the album cover you see the boom box,
you see the graffiti, the
wall in the background,
her on the trash can, her kecks,
like she's giving you that old school
gritty hip hop feel, and letting you know.
This is an album that I'm paying homage
to the greats, paying
homage to the hip hop roots.
- The Score was actually the
first album I ever bought.
I was six!
I used my little chore
money, I'll never forget,
I asked my cousin, cos
she had the cassette
and she wouldn't let me borrow it.
- When I look at the album cover
it's just like a celebration of blackness.
- I think it's really powerful
because it's like this black woman,
she has the clips in her hair
and her hair isn't pressed or anything,
it's natural, and she's just like,
"I don't care how I'm
supposed to be lookin',
"This is how I'm doing it."
- This album cover is everything,
those pictures are everything
and they're so powerful.
It created a whole new world, kind of,
for a lot of female artists.
- When I first saw it, I just remember
just like being so drawn to it,
because there's just
something very alluring
about Diana Ross in general, but like
especially on this cover
because there's like
this subtle confidence
that draws me to her.
- We used to go to the
record store in my home town,
and I remember they had it like blown up,
like a big, like a big poster,
but I just remember thinkin' like,
this dude is cool as hell.
He is lookin' at me and sayin',
do not try me, do not fuck with me,
because I will take your girl.
- I remember when I first saw it,
I really didn't think anything of it,
but later in life, as I got older,
I looked at it and I was just like,
oh crap, it's an American flag
but you have the black background
and then the white stars on top of it,
which for me means like,
America was kind of built on
the backs of black people.
- Yeah, that's my favorite
part of the cover,
because I feel like the cover itself
is just like them being
like, this is our America.
- The first time I saw this album cover
I thought that he is hung over,
or waking up from a party,
and he's simultaneously hot
and cold at the same time.
If I saw somebody wearing
a biker jacket and a Speedo
I'd be like, what's going
on in this guy's mind,
he seems a little confused, but confident,
looking right at the camera.
(laughs)
- I'm really excited to recreate the look
with the natural hair.
- I'm hyped, I'm not nervous at all.
- We cutes, though.
- Too cute, honey.
- Let's get weird, guys.
- Alright!
(laughs)
- There's always been
in the back of my mind
all these insecurities, so I don't know
if this might be a way
of sort of letting those insecurities go,
or if it might help me.
(laughs)
This is my Janet boobs.
- I am excited to dress up
in a Speedo and a biker jacket at work.
- I want everybody to
keep movin' for this one.
I am excited to recreate
this because she is one
of the most iconic artists
in American history,
and she is a black woman as well,
and she's like one of the
first huge black divas
and I feel like she basically
created the template
that all of these other
pop stars basically go by.
- I'm fuckin' excited, oh I cursed!
- Yeah, I am too.
I'm excited and nervous
about wearing leather pants.
(laughs)
- I'm assuming I'm gonna
have to like wear a wig.
He's got like the permed out.
- See, you can wear a wig, but I can't.
There's no way.
- I'm definitely excited to
kinda step back into this moment
that Michael did, I guess
he was like 24 or 25,
he defined the industry,
like let's be real.
- Oh my God, you basically
killin' that shit!
- You know I never thought
this day would come,
but now that it's here I feel
that Missy and I will
finally be the best friends
that we've been destined to be.
So Melissa, when this comes
out, when this is ready,
you know, let's get
lunch, let's get drinks.
Love you.
- Wooo hoooo!
Solange, what were you thinkin'?
I think that it was very
specific to women of color,
and women of color who
get their hair done.
We all know where to buy those clips,
and we all know where our
hairdresser keeps those clips.
Just like seeing that, there is already
an instant connection
with me and my friends.
My parents are gonna love this.
- Yeah, her brows up with the rest.
- They're totally just
surrounded by shadows,
I think that speaks a lot
to the black experience.
But they're shining beyond the shadows,
they're shining through
it and you see them.
- Ooooh, controversy.
- You see all the things that
our people are surrounded by.
- Yeah.
- If this album cover could talk,
it would just be like,
"Fuck you, this is who I am
"and this is what I came to do."
- Black is beautiful, I know that
and I will stand by it every day.
But to have an artist on
such a large platform as his,
and to be able to use his platform
to make a statement like that,
that goes leaps and bounds,
and that says so much.
The bob, and the attitude,
and the confidence,
I think we should all have that every day,
cos as Michael shows you,
it can take you places.
- Sorry Diana, can you
move back a little, okay?
- I just love inspiring figures.
She is definitely like a huge one,
in not only music history
but also black history.
- Okay, unhand me!
(laughs)
I don't know you!
If the album could talk,
I'd probably think that it would just say,
I am a woman, this is me,
and I am fierce, powerful and strong.
- Haven't worn a Speedo in a while.
Ever, maybe.
What is feminine, right?
And I think that it's kind of funny,
because now in 2017 it's like gender
is such like an old concept,
and so I think that kind
of blurring those lines
is a little bit ahead of his time.
(funky guitar)
I can but I don't want to.
- You should definitely go
back to your desk like that.
- She laid the foundation
for me as a black girl
to hold my head high.
To be confident with whatever I wear,
whatever I look like,
and how I present myself.
(funky guitar)